Was passiert, wenn ein Asteroid auf die Erde
zurast? Was sind die Konsequenzen eines Einschlags?
Jedes Jahr schlagen zahlreiche Asteroiden
auf der Erde ein, meist in Menschenleeren
Gegenden. Das Risiko ist also groß, dass
ein Einschlag, wie in Tscheljabinsk 2013,
auch mal nicht in der Atmosphäre explodiert,
sondern eine Millionenstadt trifft und zerstört.
Doch der Einschlag im Meer ist der wahrscheinlichste.
Das Los Alamos National Laboratory hat zu
diesen Szenarien intensiv geforscht und eine
erschreckende Erkenntnis gewonnen. Clixoom
Science & Fiction. Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende
Wissenschaftsvideos. Abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann und nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Los Geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen! Auf Sky Ticket startet
gerade eine spektakuläre Serie: 8 Tage. Darin
sind noch 8 Tage Zeit bis ein riesiger Asteroid
auf Europa stürzen wird und der Kontinent
zerstört wird. Schon bevor der Asteroid einschlägt
bricht das absolute Chaos aus und die Menschen
zeigen sich von ihrer schlechtesten Seite.
Denn auch das ist die Konsequenz schon des
drohenden Einschlags: Die zivile Ordnung bricht
auseinander. Ein absolut realistisches Szenario.
Man muss sich ja nur mal selber fragen, was
man tun würde, wenn Recht und Ordnung außer
Kraft gesetzt wären. Aber was droht dann
eigentlich beim Einschlag eines großen Asteroiden
mit einem Durchmesser von mehreren hundert
Metern? Die wirklich großen Brocken mit Durchmessern
von mehreren Kilometern haben wir im Blick
und in den nächsten hundert Jahren wird keiner
auf die Erde stürzen. Aber tatsächlich schlagen
ja jedes Jahr rund zwei größere Asteroiden
in menschenleeren Gegenden ein ohne, das wir
es merken. Darüber haben wir ja öfter berichtet.
Das Risiko eines größeren Einschlages auch
in bewohnten Gegenden ist also de Facto da
und die Konsequenzen reichen bis zur Zerstörung
ganzer Millionenstädte. Die NASA bereitet
sich mit ihren zahlreichen Missionen zu Asteroiden
darauf vor einen solchen Einschlag zu verhindern.
Zahlreiche Strategien dazu werden durchdacht
und sollen in Zukunft auch getestet werden.
Das Los Alamos National Laboratory hat zu
möglichen Einschlägen geforscht und ist
zu verblüffenden Erkenntnisse gekommen. 70%
der Erde sind mit Wasser bedeckt, so dass
ein Einschlag dort am wahrscheinlichsten ist.
Einen solchen Einschlag hat das Forschungsteam
durchgerechnet und ist zu einer erschreckenden
Erkenntnis gelangt. Denn ganz anders als vorhergesagt,
sind hunderte Meter hohe Tsunamis gar nicht
die schlimmste Folge. Beziehungsweise, da
gibt es sogar eine Entwarnung. Da der Einschlag
punktförmig ist, verlieren sie ihre Energie
sehr schnell und sind ab einer Entfernung
des Einschlags von mehr als 20 Kilometern
mit aller wahrscheinlichkeit gar nicht mehr
gefährlich. Etwas ganz anderes könnte die
furchtbare Konsequenz sein. Mehrer hundert
Megatonnen Wasser werden durch den Einschlag
bis in die Stratosphäre katapultiert. Ein
Teil davon sehr schnell über den Eintrittsweg
des Asteroiden, weil er hier ein Teilvakuum
zurückgelassen hat, dass jetzt das Wasser
ansaugt. In der Stratosphäre kann das Wasser
dann Monate oder Jahre verbleiben und heizt
dann den Treibhauseffekt auf der Erde weiter
an. Das wäre die schlimmste Katastrophe und
könnte zu Millionen Toten führen. Sprich:
Ein Einschlag direkt in eine Millionenstadt
wäre zwar verheerend und würde sie wahrscheinlich
wie eine Atombombe vernichten. Ein Einschlag
in einen Ozean aber könnte weitaus verheerender
sein, weil er Auswirkungen auf die ganze Erde
haben würde! Bam! Und jetzt geht es weiter
mit der Endzeitserie 8 Tage! Dafür hier draufklicken
und ihr spart damit 50%. Streamt mit dem Entertainment-Ticket
bis Ende April neben den Highlights ‘8 Tage’,
‘The Walking Dead’ und ‘Game Of Thrones’
auch tausend weitere Serien-Highlights. Damit
könnt’ ihr ​bis Ende April Serien genießen​
und den März’ ​ab jetzt bekommt ihr
zusätzlich noch ​oben drauf! Bis dann,
bleibt dran!